Philippians,
I love the Philippines.
I've been there three times already.
I'm probably going there for a fourth
time pretty soon.
Good evening everyone.
Welcome to my office space slash
language lab.
This is where I do my work.
This is where I study when I'm studying
a language.
Um,
and I wanted to talk to you about,
uh,
the next language that I'm thinking of
picking up the language or the main
national language of this place,
which is Philippians.
I love the Philippines.
I've been there three times already.
I'm probably going there for a fourth
time pretty soon,
so I thought it might be fun to learn a
bit.
It's a catalog.
I don't actually have to really learn it
because most people in Philippines speak
English really quite well.
Not everyone,
but most people speak English well
enough that I don't need to learn
tagalog,
but if I'm going to spend that much time
in the Philippines then it would make
sense to,
to try to learn some of the language and
just have some fun with it and see how
far they take it.
My main project right now is French,
so tagalog catalogs not going to be my
main thing,
but I want it to give it a go,
have some fun with it and if I go back
there numerous times,
maybe I'll study and improve a little
bit each time and just have that basic
knowledge I can use.
So let's have a look at how I'm going to
do it.
Where I'm going to start.
Okay.
We're going to jump right into my
computer just like this.
Here we go.
Alright.
So here we are inside my computer.
You can see I'm on a page right here
with this image of a pimsleur program.
This is pimsleur Tagalog.
Pimsleur is a language course that is
all audio.
You don't use any text.
Usually you don't learn the grammar
explicitly.
You just,
uh,
you learned through listening and
responding and repeating with the CD.
Now it,
they market it really heavily and they,
they talked like this one program will
make you fluent and stuff,
but it's not the be all end all.
But I really like to use some kind of
audio program at the beginning when I
start learning a language because I want
to get familiar with the phonology,
the sounds,
the pronunciation quite quickly,
both for understanding them and for
producing them.
Uh,
so I like to get some program like this
so I can focus on the cds,
learn them,
go over them a few times if I need to.
Uh,
this one is 30 lessons,
so it usually takes like a month if you
do one lesson per day.
Uh,
but after I do the first couple of
lessons and just get familiar with the
basic sounds,
then I'm going to,
I'll keep doing this program.
But after the first couple of lessons,
I'm going to find a teacher so I can get
some more practice producing the
language and using it a building my oral
communication skills.
So I'm going to use something called Iot
Talky,
which is a,
it's a website that matches you with
tutors or teachers of the language want
to learn.
So there's a scroll down the list here,
a dropdown menu.
You can find the language of your
choice.
Here is fulfilled Pino or Tagalog,
so let's click on that and I want
someone who also speaks English.
That's most people in Philippines,
so let's browse and see how many
teachers are available.
All right.
We could see there are a lots of Gallo
teachers available and the prices are
very good.
Fit for this is like five to $10.
This is $5 per hour.
This woman charges six to $9 per hour,
basically about $5 per hour.
So the prices are awesome because
Philippines is a developing country,
so to them maybe that's good money,
but it's important to point out that
these are our tutors.
They're not always professional teachers
who give you a structured lesson,
but that's what I want.
I want someone to practice speaking with
just so I can practice making sentences,
practice getting exposure to the
language that I hear and can produce it
with someone and see if they understand.
So it's all about building oral
communication skills.
So step one is get familiar with the
sound.
Step two is find a teacher.
Start to produce the language and use
the sounds and learn to understand them.
In a speaking situation,
another resource I'm going to use is
this,
this is the lonely planet Filipino or
Tagalog phrase book.
I really liked using phrase books when I
start learning a language because they
give me a lot of examples of very simple
basic sentences so it gives me a good
chance to internalize the sentence
structure so I can just go over
examples,
examples with simple vocabulary and then
I can start to substitute some of the
words,
change out the words to make my own
sentences following the same pattern of
the sentence that's right in front of me
and the book and also you have the
English right next to the language so
you can.
You can compare the sentences and figure
out which words mean what in the other
language.
So that gives you a good sense of how to
build sentences from their component
pieces.
So I really liked to do that phrase.
Books are really useful if you use them
correctly in that when I'm also going to
use a more traditional kind of textbook.
This one,
Tagalog for beginners.
I'm going to start with the kindle
version just because I want to use it
today and it comes with some audios as
well.
Uh,
if I like it,
I'll get the paper back because I
generally don't like to get language
books on kindle,
but I just want it today,
so I'm going to get it.
This one according to the reviews as the
best.
I haven't looked at it,
but I'm going to go for this one because
of the reviews.
I like to have some kind of traditional
textbook when I'm studying a language
because it gives me a bit of that
conscious understanding of,
uh,
of the language.
So with the phrase book that can just do
it on my own.
I can figure things out,
but they're always going to be times
when I'm somewhat confused or I want
some confirmation of what I'm.
So these traditional textbooks usually
give you the grammar and the vocabulary
and all that with some explanation of
how to use them and what they mean.
So I'm going to have those components.
I'm going to have the pimsleur for,
uh,
getting familiar with the sounds of the
pronunciation.
Then I'm going to find a teacher,
start talking right away.
Then I'm going to use the phrase book
and I'm going to get familiar with the
sentence structure and I'm going to do
some traditional learning study a little
bit in this textbook every day,
so those are the things I'm planning to
do.
I'm going to get started and enjoy
learning tagalog and we'll see how it
goes.
Alright,
now it's time to edit this video.
Let me move this down.
Here we go.
Let's move this one down here.